[Music]
we were here to celebrate a great uh
city in the state of florida freedom
city and it's important that when you
have the federal government overreaching
like joe biden's doing that we sign
legislation to protect floridians and
doing it here in brandon you know i
think is especially meaningful because i
think people here really appreciate it
so we were proud to have a huge turnout
of folks that came to watch what was
going on and we're proud to be able to
deliver substantively for workers in the
state of florida brandon florida has
become the shining city on the hill
it is not lost on floridians
or the american people that this
administration
continues to make reckless misguided
policy decisions with no regard for the
ultimate consequences of for in the
individual well-being of the american
people
as long as you can
continue to see these types of decisions
short-sighted reckless political
decisions without true understanding of
consequences or the individual
circumstances of the people their
decisions are affecting
you'll continue to see people pushing
back whether that's let's go brandon
whether that's pushback among
communities and
you know
whether that's a chant or whether that's
demonstrating it in legal action to
formally push back
i think you'll continue to see that
throughout this administration to be
clear because of our efforts because
when president biden said
bring it on
dare to challenge me as president of the
united states who's going to impose my
will
and authority on every
american the majority of american
workers we said fine we will we've been
successful
there's a stay on the ocean mandate we
expect we will see success in our other
actions and so to be clear right now
there is absolutely no federal mandate
as it pertains to the osha rule that
will require florida workers to be
vaccinated while we are pushing back
legally against the
sweeping federal mandates that are
totally unlawful there's no basis in
federal law that would allow for a
president of the united states to
mandate
these vaccine vaccines federally we knew
within florida
if we're successful federally and
pushing back as i suspect suspect we
will be
we wanted to make sure florida
not only what came out strong i've also
had success in appearing in cases where
we're protecting government employees
that have been told by munich by cities
that they had to be mandated police
officers firefighters we knew we needed
to clarify that law and we also knew we
needed to do something within florida
and that's what our legislature has done
and so it's a two-front uh protection of
the florida worker